and reminder that every American will be better
off when all Americans have a decent education
good jobs adequate housing and know that they
belong to the greater society that will be built
on hardwork black and white working together
but I would say that anyone is concerned about
any various problems dealing with our community
should take upon themselves to go to the Urban
League because I see this as one of the avenues
to travel although the issues raised at the
symposium have been with us for generations
there are creative new approaches to solving
these problems everywhere around Chicago there
are bright new ideas been successfully applied
our job is to get around the roadblocks to show
that change can occur without disruption that's
our priority for the third century and we
intend to make it Chicago's priority as well
Chicago like America as a whole takes in a lot
more than lines on a map Chicago is an urban
force upon the American land it is a necessary
element of what we mean by civilization the city
at its best balancing man and his perspectives
the quality of life with the quality of life
and I try to explain to the children
that you can only live for today you
have to live for tomorrow - and when you
encourage yourself and your children like
that one of these days if you don't
make it then one of them will [Music]